let's just do a little bit quick on on
Syria right now because it seems to me
by every estimation it's no longer a
country under any under any
circumstances that we consider a
functioning country and it seems to me
that we're at this point also basically
just in a proxy war we the United States
pretty much in a proxy war with Russia
am I completely oversimplifying it at
this point well no I mean it's not quite
a proxy war with Russia it's something
else look the the truth is is that Syria
is the end of Syria the endgame in Syria
as well which I think we probably are in
now is the endgame that Assad and the
Iranians always wanted which is Assad
against Isis because if it's a sad
against Isis they know that the world
will not back Isis and you know earlier
this year Assad was interviewed by
Jeremy Bowen at the BBC and you know sad
you know talks about the Opposition as
these terrorists of Isis and you know
some years ago he wouldn't have be able
to get away with that so much she still
can't completely get away with that line
now but some years ago he certainly
couldn't III knew and worked with some
members of Syrian opposition more than
15 years ago I think to begin with and
know and knew that there were people who
were very good who wanted their country
not to be run by the Bashar Assad family
forever and wanted Syria to be the great
country it could be all of their hopes
have gone most those people are dead now
and Assad has got what he wanted the
Iranians have got what they wanted no
one will bag Isis quite rightly so in
the end will allow us and to remain in
power
look this is to some extent what happens
when we don't take any interest and
don't really get involved I I've always
been against us intervening in any major
way in Syria for one reason in
particular which was that I always said
that after Iraq and Afghanistan we
should realize that we clearly don't
have the desire the willpower or produce
the people anymore in your country or
who want to spend you know 20 or 30
years in this country governing bits of
it helping with infrastructure problems
or anything else we're good at going in
and and doing the first phase but we're
no good at the follow-up and we should
realize that and in the meantime not be
responsible for any country's collapse
the who's who's nation-building
afterwards we really don't want to do so
you're not a very good neoconservative
that I think because wouldn't because
wouldn't all the people that are gonna
label you neoconservative would say you
should be for all these things well the
people who do the labels never listened
to actually say so what what should we
do then basically I mean without without
really blaming Syria because I know we
could talk about it for two hours I mean
at this point watching this country just
collapse and Russia fill the vacuum what
should the role of the West be I don't
think we have much of a role now as I
say our other the opportunity for for
backing the good guys that window closed
very early in the conflict the truth is
is that the future of Syria is not going
to be in American hands it probably
never was it's certainly not and never
was going to be in British hands Iran
will win in Syria Russia will win in
Syria Bashar al-assad will win in Syria
and everyone else including most the
Syrian people lose that's that's the end
game that's the result yeah yeah yeah I
mean I I basically agree with you on
that how much of this do you think is
that it's it's very obvious that that
Obama just wanted out of this part of
the world he just simply wanted out and
the way we left Iraq and everything else
I was against I was against us going
into Libya I was against Syria all of
this stuff but to your earlier point it
seems like even if we do something
everyone hates us and if we don't do
anything everyone hates us that the
ultimate irony here many others as well
but yes I mean it is true that it when
America acts it gets blamed and when it
doesn't act it gets blamed
and sometimes that blame is is worth
listening to and sometimes it isn't I
mean to some extent it hat you have to
listen to who it comes from I would say
when people who criticize America or her
allies or country like Britain do so as
helpful critics you can usually tell and
when people criticize America or Britain
or any other country and they're
speaking as enemies you can also tend to
tell so you know there are lots of
things that we can learn from this
period I would think it would be very
regrettable if America decided that the
response to all of this would be that
the America would say well we no one
ever loved us anyway so we're going home
you know you wouldn't have America to
kick around anymore sort of lachrymose a
Jeb Bush like line and I hope I hope
that America doesn't take that view but
you know Obama I hope everyone also
learns the lesson of Obama on this I
mean Obama's predecessor and found all
sorts of ways to mark out Middle East
but Obama has as well wholly new ways in
in some ways you know bomb was meant to
be the president - who brought the
troops home and brought peace and there
at least and you know he did a bit of
that but he certainly hasn't brought
peace anymore than the waters receded
and all that other stuff it's been a
very I think the Obama presidency at the
end of it people will realize not that
his predecessors were terrific and that
he wasn't anything but that but the
noblest aspirations can all go wrong in
wholly different ways yeah doesn't that
Egypt speech the speech he gave in Cairo
which really was the reset doesn't that
seem like not just a different time it
almost feels like it was from a
different planet at this point yeah
right as did the Russia reset and as
does the Russia reset now you know after
9/11 dick Armitage famously said to the
Pakistani ambassador who was saying you
know oh we know news your guff about you
know when I assign someone don't know
that we know about al-qaeda and all this
sort of stuff dig Armitage was said to
have banged the table and when the
Pakistani ambassador said you know
there's a lot of history and he said to
bang the table and say history starts
today it's a very noble threat but it's
never true history didn't start
our 911 it didn't start with the
beginning of the first Obama
administration I I wish we were wiser
about this any yeah well I think in a
world of Twitter and vine and short
videos our attention span just is frayed
to the point that people just forget
history people just don't really care
about history so one more quick thing on
Syria then we'll move on the refugee
situation in Europe which I'm seeing
these videos every day coming out of all
sorts of different you know from Denmark
and Sweden and Germany just it sounds
like an absolutely terrible situation
and what I think is most interesting
about it is nobody had heard about any
of it a month ago I mean it basically
started a month maybe five six weeks ago
something like that before that it
seemed like there was no refugee crisis
and now it seems like an epic refugee
crisis well I don't know well in Britain
and across Europe I mean seven southern
Europe it's been going on for a very
long time
obviously and southern Europeans
Italians and the Greeks and particular
been asking for help for a very long
time and if you go as I did earlier this
year at the end of lamb Purdue's though
in south of Italy it's nearer to Libya
than it is to anything else in Italy
inkling Sicily you didn't see the graves
of migrants who tried to get over going
back 15 years or more so it is quite a
long developing story
it's true that every year in recent
years when you get towards the summer
months there's a surge obviously it's
easier to cross the waters during those
months this is by the way I mean this is
such a hugely complex story and it's one
that really we're all getting wrong it's
a classic example of the sort of Twitter
age not being not being really fit for
purpose because this is one of the most
extraordinary in vast migrations that
we've seen and it's being misunderstood
by almost everybody the majority of the
migrants who are coming into Europe and
not from Syria the Syrians comprise of a
minority of the migrants you can pick
your percentages some people think it's
an hour and 20% some people up to 40 it
it varies obviously between the points
of entry but the vast majority are
coming from all over the world so of
people from Bangladesh people from
coming from the farther east than that
there are people the majority I would
think I might make my own observation
coming from sub-saharan Africa so when
you hear statesman saying and pundits
and others saying well you know we need
to solve Syria for instance and then
we'll solve the migrant crisis these
people don't know what they're talking
about even if it was an America or
Britain or any other countries gift to
solve the humanitarian catastrophe of
Syria that would only solve a part of
the migrant crisis yeah what's your plan
for Eritrea has anyone got one has
anyone thought of one can anyone point
to Eritrea on a map yeah we are so not
fit for purpose in rising to this
challenge and all that can happen I
don't if he's having to lower the tone
somewhat benedict cumberbatch one of my
compatriots it was on stage in London
the other night finished the performance
of Hamlet and berated the crowd and
berated British politicians for not
bringing in enough people that is the
clever caring thing to say at the moment
we must open our doors refugees welcome
do you know what in the UK a recent poll
showed only 7% of the British people
wanted immigration into the UK to
increase 7% it's the same across Europe
people don't mind accepting genuine
refugees but no one knows what to do
with a number of refugees genuine
refugees who are coming and absolutely
nobody knows including Chancellor Merkel
who having saved the IRB's in the
financial crisis has now totally
floundered on the refugee crisis Angela
Merkel doesn't know what to do the
European Commission just recently tried
to force quotas on European countries
they don't hate migrants they couldn't
and didn't want to take and as the
European Commission issued that they
admitted that that number they were
talking about was not fit for purpose
because the number was so much higher
what I'm trying to convey it this is a
continent-wide catastrophe which we are
at the big
and I think as I say we haven't even
begun to rise to it and we're gonna see
I think terrible things winter's coming
Sweden is now putting refugees in tents
because it's run out of properties
Sweden took the view let's let's show
the world how generous we are let's be
they said a humanitarian superpower now
they're gonna have to raise taxes
they've got increasing public opinion
against them and the top party in the
polls in Sweden the humanitarian a hyper
power of Sweden is the party that's
generally called far-right that's now
top of the polls in Sweden yeah yeah is
that is that what's coming next because
that is what I fear that I think
somebody like bender benedict
cumberbatch I think there's some well
intent to intentioned humanistic thing
going on here well I don't know about
that actually I mean maybe maybe they
just want to look like they're doing
that but but if you you know you can
track to a really core mistake right
here if you want to be generous be
generous but don't demand other people
to be generous for you a the head of the
Scottish Nationalist Party a little
while ago said she would be willing to
take in a Syrian family it's months
since she said that and as far as I know
there are no Syrians living with her one
of the top members the Labour Party said
the same thing months ago so far as I
know she hasn't got a Syrian family in
her house um I think this is posturing
and it really it's not sincere because
if you said to those people look at the
numbers that are actually coming and
look at the numbers of people who say
they want to come you will realize that
it is not only economically but
societally unsustainable right so the
you would have to realise that yeah so
under the best of circumstances bringing
these people in would be extremely
difficult and basically what you're
saying is we're doing this or this is
being done under the worst of
circumstances because there's just
simply no controls here well as nobody
does nobody knows who's coming most
people destroy their papers before they
get here most people pretend to be a
Syrians even when they're very obviously
not
and the truth is as I've seen in
covering this story in the south of
Europe the truth is is that once too in
European waters you're you're in Europe
and you never you never go back there's
no there's no particularly good way even
when this was at a low point there was
no particularly sophisticated way to
work out who was who and to work out who
was genuine and who was an economic
migrant and that whole system is
basically broken down now so once you're
in you're in and I think this is going
to it's going to obviously approve a
potentially breaking change for Europe
because these are the only Germany's
meant to be bringing 1% of its current
population in in addition every year for
the foreseeable future
who pays for that who pays for those
people I mean you know I'm not heartless
about this I would like to see
everywhere genuine refugees get asylum
in countries hopefully return to their
countries and help rebuild them when
they're safe again but I would like
genuine asylum seekers to get a sign but
the moment the whole thing is so tied up
that actually I think that Europe's
heart is going to harden towards all of
these people and in that lack of
attention to the detail I think yes
across Europe we see a catastrophe
started yeah what do you make of the
Gulf countries you know Kuwait Bahrain
United Arab Emirates etc I read this
morning that the six main Gulf countries
have taken in zero refugees yes what
these are their brothers are they not I
mean what's going on here brothers in
the same way that the Palestinians are
their brothers yes well look the Gulf
state countries bring in no Syrian
refugees and one one qat official in a
recent interview was asked why and said
an interview in Arabic it's it's on the
net I said that the reason was because
Kuwait you have to understand he said
that we are very fragile and countries
we are we can't take in all these people
they are traumatized they come from a
different culture you know it's a
different culture Syria we can
put up with them in the Gulf right it's
much more like Sweden why don't you go
to Norway Sweden and so on and you see
it's another thing of people's good
instinct being used against them
Europeans here that don't hear that
what Europeans see is catastrophe what
did we do we must be responsible what's
our responsibility we must do this we
must do it even if it breaks us and and
over in the Gulf taking in zero people
and they don't give a damn about it and
frankly I think they probably find it
quite funny that the Europeans have
fallen for the idea that this whole
catastrophe is the fault of the
Europeans yeah all right so I do want to
move on but I have to back up for a
second so what are you thinking in the
mind of someone like Angola Merkel what
do you think she's actually thinking she
has to know that it's not sustainable
right and I get it she's either trying
to have these lofty goals of trying to
do something on humanitarian grounds or
whatever Pope
what do you think really is going on in
her head also knowing that as you said
before this probably is going to
strengthen the far-right in Germany yeah
I mean Germany it may it may not
actually be possible to solve it because
in Germany for all sorts of obvious
historical reasons if you if you say
France if you say in Britain I don't
know we might have a migration so large
that a British culture and British side
will basically over if you were to say
that if you it's not true at the moment
but I mean if somewhere down the road
you were to say that you you would still
look most British people sort of think
that you know well nice guy we enjoy
ourselves a country we've been bored
lift force for good in the world they
wouldn't want Britain to be over Germany
has a different thing there are a lot of
people in Germany who for historical
reasons and some understandable
historical reasons basically think that
German guilt can never be alleviated and
that anything other than the destruction
of Germany could never never read
Germany of its sins Wow now my own view
is that those people maybe in the years
ahead themselves in a minority I think
it's quite hard to tell young Germans
that because of something their
grandparents did they have to abolish
themselves as a country or as a society
but they've definitely got the problem
harder now you can see that in Angela
Merkel's response Angela Merkel when she
was asked recently at a press conference
by a nice German lady who just sort of
said you know isn't this isn't this a
problem for our country I am concerned
for my country
it was just brushed off by Angela Merkel
as if this woman was some whack-job
weirdo who come from racist Ville yeah
and you see this all throughout let me
give you another very quick example of
their least pegida protests which I
don't agree with I'm concerned about
them but I think that they are there all
sorts of a they are obviously nante
Islam protests they also Mountain
migration prices and all sorts of other
things but it's the legitimate use of
people's time is legitimate political
grievance and needs the needs to have an
airing Angela Merkel uses her New Year
message to say that the pegida
protesters have coldness in their hearts
if instead of that sheep said the
Islamists who the budino protests are
mainly concerned about how coldness in
their hearts and we as Germans must be
careful not in response to this hatred
to become hateful ourselves then that
might be saying but because the anglo
Merkel's problem is she can only deal
with secondary problems she can't deal
with the primary ones very very I said
that would be a five point final final
point yeah I don't know if you saw it
but the other week a fascinating thing
happened at the UN in New York Angela
Merkel was sitting next to Mark
Zuckerberg for lunch
and unfortunately Angela Merkel's
microphone was hot everyone in politics
has had a hot mic moment right but her
mic was still on it possibly the worst
moment could have been Verma Mays it
hasn't been picked up more but she sat
down to lunch beside Mark Zuckerberg in
September in New York and said whilst
the mic was on Tamar's look about what
can we do to stop people writing
anti-immigration things on Facebook and
Mark Zuckerberg says we're working on it
now look I say this as quickly as
possible if you want to create a volcano
in Europe the best way to do it would be
to shut down and stop legitimate public
feeling about things and to say that is
no good saying that you object to the
migration on Facebook he should be
stopped
that is the big
way fastest way to make sure the volcano
blows out of the side yeah and it seems
so obvious to me that this is what the
regressive left has done by labeling
everyone who doesn't agree with them
racist they've created a situation where
good intention people liberals are now
finding themselves agreeing on a lot of
things with people on the far-right who
they agree with nothing else on sure
that's the thing I think I think I think
the fact is is that what the left has
done in recent years with the term
racist has basically ended up deleting
the term of having any meaning and or M
or much meaning anyway because if
everybody can be called a racist at some
point and generally very often at least
for various grounds it means that you've
basically got no terminology left when
an actual racist comes along and I can
sort of sense that people just they're
going to end up not caring in the future
I've always said I want this so loved
I want this problem these sort of
problems dealt with in order that
they're not dealt in the coming decades
by marine lepen and the your haider ish
elements in Austria but you know too few
people listen
you